notre invité principal ce soir c'est
roberto alagna
un roberto alagna bonsoir c'est l'un des
plus grands ténors du monde et pour les
néophytes on peut dire que vous êtes une
sorte de castafiore mais en est qu
vous êtes chanteur d'opéra et pourtant
vous avez une coiffure de joueurs de
foot c'est
d'un garage de la banlieue parisienne
aux scènes des plus grands opéras du
monde votre vie est inimaginable on va
voir vous êtes né dans le 9 3 ouais
comme joey starr d'ailleurs la première
fois que vous avez entendu du mozart
vous avez dit [ __ ] bbc de la balle
vous êtes né donc dans le 9-3 à clichy
sous bois le 7 juin 1963 dans un garage
prêté par un ami de votre père est
pourquoi dans un garage parce qu'à
l'époque à clichy-sous-bois n'y avait
pas encore de celle m et tout ça donc
mais ma famille venait d'arriver de
sicile et il fallait s'arranger pour
avoir des donc des logements ouais et ce
voisin qui l'a proposé ce garage à mon
père mon père était maçon donc là il l'a
transformé en jolie un jaune et un joli
nid et voilà je suis né là dedans mais
c'était bien alors c'est un bébé fragile
vous êtes presque mort-né lui dit ma
survie est un miracle oui oui c'est vrai
parce que je me mettais à étouffer avec
le cordon ombilical et donc il a fallu
me voir animer avec le bouche à bouche
et je n'allais pas pleurer donc c'est le
comble pour un chanteur donc de quoi
faire de son alors votre père francesco
donc été maçon il y avait la fibre
artistique a chanté toute la journée
votre mère lucia est couturière puis
assistante maternelle elle se passionne
pour l'art lyrique dont famille
sicilienne très beau mais très heureuse
ouais pauvre normal quand on est heureux
parce que la musique est parce que le
chant et puis la famille alors tous les
dimanches touchante à la fin du repas on
sort les mandolines on tape sur les
tables on reprend des tubes sicilien
comme ce qu'il ya dans votre disque
actuellement je me souviens que ma grand
mère nous disait toujours de chanter en
sourdine pour déranger les voisins
réalisé deux lycées cette musique là ça
va les déranger et puis aujourd'hui
quand on voit le succès de siciliens
tendance à une belle revanche
roberto alagna une énorme star
génial alors à l'époque évidemment
l'exil est encore proche il n'y a pas de
télé pour voir le pays pour entendre la
langue et chanter c'est tout ce qui vous
raccorde avec votre famille au pays à la
sicile ouais c'est vrai c'est pour ça
qu'on fait ça du matin au soir alors
votre père chante aussi évidemment donc
il a son petit peu ce de radio il a pour
nom du hit parade alors ils chantent tom
jones il chante très francs soit un tous
les chanteurs du hit parade et c'est
comme ça que vous découvrez en fait la
variété et il existe un enregistrement
de vous avez quatre ans et vous chantez
j'avais pas vu mirza quoi
en italien c'était une chanson qui est
qu'ils aient parlé d'un chien donc ça me
plaisait
alors ce qui est terrible c'est qu'elle
est peu vous êtes extrêmement timide
donc craintifs
vous chantez vos premières chansons en
cachette devant votre soeur qui doit
garder le secret 1
bah oui parce qu'il y avait quand même
des sacrés chanteur dans la famille et
donc moi je passais derrière j'étais un
peu timide donc voilà donc je me cachais
et puis j'ai pris confiance avec la
guitare c'était une armure or voilà à 12
ans vous mets au conservatoire pour vous
soyez le premier de la famille à savoir
lire la musique et vous détestez le
solfège c'était le côté académique ouais
moi qui me dérangeait il fallait fallait
aller à une certaine heure et moi
j'avais bien être un petit peu j'étais
complètement anti académique alors c'est
une époque où vous découvrez le le
rock'n'roll vous avez un vrai coup de
foudre pour le rock and roll c'était
surtout pour elvis en fait ce qui me
plaisait chez elvis était la voix senna
qu'elle vit ce qu'il a fait ou sous les
minima
et
[Applaudissements]
voilà
aura 15 ans malgré l'opposition de vos
parents vous commencé à chanter tous les
week-ends en public dans une pizzeria la
pizzeria d'un copain de classe et vous
avez énormément de succès les gens font
la queue ouais ouais ça s'appelait le
let nappes et j'en mettais des billets
lors sur la guitare c'est assez
réconfortant bien sûr on voyait le
succès tout de suite ouais à 17 ans la
vous passez dans les cabarets parisiens
le pussycat la madrague millau chez
vincent chanter de minuit à 6 heures du
matin fait 70 chansons ça a duré presque
huit ans alors voilà vous dormez trois
heures par jour et dans la journée vous
prenez des cours de chant avec un vieux
professeur cubain qui s'appelle rafael
ruiz et là un jour au comble de
l'émotion ce monsieur vous dit que vous
êtes un ténor j'y crois pas aux débuts
de sattel ma mère je dis tu sais le
professeur me dit que je suis ténor m
dit non non laisse tomber c'est parce
qu'il va te prendre de l'argent 10 mai
et alors là tu as varutti seront à paris
et après une séance d'autographes il
écarte la barrière il s'approche de vous
majestueusement évidemment c'est pas la
rôtie il vous prend dans ses bras oui il
m'emmène avec lui comme ça dans une
petite salle et puis il vous fait une
accolade italienne ouais ouais comme
dans la mafia
on sait pas embrassé sur la bouche mais
bon
c'était une magnifique parce que à un
moment j'ai cru que c'était un rêve
c'est vrai que j'avais rêvé c'est parce
qu'il est parti comme ça il s'est
engouffré dans une voiture tout le monde
l'a suivi je me suis retrouvé tout seul
avec mon verre de champagne et j'ai cru
avoir rêvé et en fait j'avais l'adresse
sans adresse mais voilà alors là vous
gagnerez donc le premier prix du
concours va rôti à philadelphie ce qui
lance effectivement votre carrière
pavarotti le ténorissimo comment
l'appeler le 24 février 88 il a battu le
record du monde de rappel 165 rappelle
1h07 d'aplomb sans arrêt c'est
incroyable et un klaxon au monde qui ait
jamais eu ça vous c'est quoi votre
coffre est méritée non mais c'est pas
parce que moi je ne suis pas trop pour
ça mais vous quand vous faites l'amour z
et rappelle quand même
donc là vous devenez le quatrième ténor
après pavarotti carreiras et domingo
après elle c'est génial love story avec
en guise à giorgio vous êtes mariés sur
la scène du metropolitan à new york par
le maire rudolf giuliani vous devenez le
couple star de l'opéra mondiale et le 14
juillet 2005 vous chanter la
marseillaise place de la concorde en
présence de jacques chirac il dit ce
jour là je me suis senti vraiment
français mais moi je suis devenu
français sans le demander simplement
parce que j'étais né en france et j'ai
appris à me sentir français donc née au
départ c'était difficile puisque quand
même toutes mes racines ont été ainsi
bien je me sentais quand même étrange et
aussi bien en france qu'en italie et ce
jour là j'ai pris conscience que mon
pays c'était la france et que c'était
beau de chanter cet hymne magnifique on
critique souvent mais
alors voilà
fait un boulot quand même trédudon la
veille des représentations les fois vous
dormez pas ça me permet d'apprendre des
rôles pendant ce temps là ouais alors ce
qui est incroyable c'est que dans un
spectacle vous perdez 3 à 4 kg et vous
avez des pantalons de scène avec des
ceintures et intérieurs spécial pour
éviter qu'ils glissent qu'on veut a
maigri et engage
la vérité c'est fini je savais pas du
tout alors votre visage se gonfle un peu
à cause des efforts musculaires que vous
faites c'est tous les chanteurs d'opéra
vous allez voir car en début de carrière
ils ont un visage est alors en fin de
carrière il en a un qui est le double
alors c'était la grosse tête parce que
non c'est pas ça du tout parce que les
chanteurs d'opéra ne peuvent pas avoir
la grosse tête parce qu'on met notre
titre en jeu à chaque soir c'est un peu
comme les boxeurs alors c'est un boulot
très prenants vous est booké jusqu'en
2014 un certain niveau dans l'opéra on
est obligés de préparer les scènes les
partenaires les castings les productions
donc touch fait 5 ans la vente mais
c'est pas simplement pour moi un c pour
tous les chanteurs d'un certain niveau
et je suis ravi cette fois ci avec la
tournée sicilienne puisque je vais
passer un mois en france et ça je suis
content parce que il ya ça fait plus de
vingt ans que j'ai passé un mois
d'affilée en france donc à partir du 17
avril donc il ya une tournée des zénith
le 20 avril êtres à bercy et puis alors
il ya le dise donc sicilien
500000 exemplaires vendus c'est
incroyable ça n'arrive plus à me ferais
peut on parlerait pas un petit peu
d'opéra aussi quand même à vous fait
toujours de l'opéra j'en ferai
parce que j'aime au final au tennis pour
faire la promo des vrais oui merci de le
remarquer parce que d'ailleurs il ya un
joli dvd qui est sorti oui si en ce
moment et qui s'appelle orphée et
eurydice de glück c'est très beau je
vous le conseille vous pouvez pas
méchante et l'instruction vous casser la
voix truc comme ça si c'est bien là le
parrain la
bouche à la luna et michel hellio
glochos d'amour et faut casser groupe
soma tamoul l'homme et
l'animal chez
abdulhadin
nucci d'arracher maquis malanou tada
odem vos bras sa
mono nagui yona nous chez my soul et
s'il donne à la
victime la démission les corrections de
ne rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu